the 1628 Japan grab which was something
that you had never tried before you
decided I'll try it during my Olympic
performance Rea that happens and you
killed it you nailed it and then you win
the gold are you working on any new
tricks
yeah I've been working on a couple new
ones one that probably might not be
allowed in the next Olympics though it's
uh my friend standing on the jump with a
camera and a front flip over him and
grab it you front flip over your friend
who's filming you with a camera grab the
camera and then you flip and grab the
camera during the flip yeah I think we
have a clip of you doing this is that
right that's too late let's do that out
let's to that up this is so scary
I love how yeah he would be scared
because I missed that you killed him
[Music]
you